i saw some commercials for this
program during a lot of football games
yeah yeah it's
uh all six episodes are going to be
available to stream starting on thursday
coyote
exclusively on cbs all access a story
of a man who after 32 years as a border
patrol agent
forced to work for the very people he
spent his career trying to keep out of
america
and it challenges his ideology and
loyalties and then he's on the
on the other side of the wall on a
different team so
if you remove the number 32 and put the
number say
20 after spending 20 years with one team
and then goes
and tries to figure out how to do a job
differently
for another team is coyote the story of
tom brady
[Laughter]
you know i'm trying to draw some
parallels i might be i might be reaching
but there's one person asked the man who
plays ben clemons
in the new show coyote michael chiklis
how are you michael
i'm very well retired how are you are
there are there any parallels here
did for you to at this very point of
your career
take a role about somebody who spends so
much time with one side and
goes and tries to figure things out from
another team michael is there any
parallel here
certainly uh there are many parallels
that can be drawn richard
is that you can go somewhere else yes
and
learn quite a lot about yourself and
find success in those places too
okay um i can full throatedly
uh support uh
tb12 uh-huh in his endeavor as
my team is no longer in the hunt
i did notice that i did notice that um
so let's take this one step at a time
before we do get actually seriously into
your new show in your new role
um how have you been uh approaching this
season as a die hard patriot fan who
loves tom brady the point where you have
named your pug
tb12 so just as you would imagine i've
been watching both teams and rooting for
both of them and
you know uh and figuring i would cross
bridges when i got to them
if if that you know if they met
in combat but that as is not going to be
the case
so at least it makes it cleaner for me i
you know
man we only have 10 minutes so i can't
give you all of my opinions
please michael please please the floor
is yours
the floor is hello uh hey man listen
uh i am a little
kind of astounded at what happened with
the patriots this year i
am frankly i you know um
you know there's some clear
disappointments obviously
uh but still you know they i think that
they go beyond
the quarterback position um and i've
just been sort of like huh
you know i'm saddened because you know i
really
truly can relate now eisen because
you are a yankees chad yes sir and i can
truly say you know i kind of understand
now what it is to have a dynasty and to
watch that dynasty end
[Laughter]
all right well you open the door let's
stroll through it uh
i will ask i will ask my fellow mass
hole on the setter you've met many times
uh
chris brockman chris brockman chris how
many other teams did derek jeter uh play
for
how many other teams did cherokee play
for he only played for one okay how many
other teams
did mariana rivera feel forced to go
somewhere else did he ever go somewhere
else no he retired
oh right i don't i mean you just walked
you just
you know you just killed off the the
yankee dynasty which
you know i guess they've they haven't
won in uh
over a decade but no i i i i can
pick up what you're putting down is what
i'm saying
michael well no i no i think you're
inferring something else altogether i
mean
you know again there has to be a
convergence of things
you know you know i i i should have
known
no no you're lashing out at me michael i
understand
how about this i'll offer this up at
least you still swept the jets at least
that
at least at least out of out of this at
this abnormal season
uh for you um and patriot fans
more
that is to watch such
you know to go from such heights right
to just
you know not make the playoffs i mean
wow yeah and and and oh
but look uh oh god no but blood pressure
all right so then let's talk about the
good stuff then
tb12 looking as great as he really
i mean he finished very strong damn near
a thousand yards in his last ten
quarters you know i've been saying to
people every week that they remain in it
they become a bigger and bigger threat
because the
you know that's tom he continues
to grind and work and study and
just won't take no for an answer and
he loves it when people count him out
and that that sort of feeds him and
i don't know what kind of dorian gray
deal he has satan but
you know the 43 of it all i just don't
that's something that's special and
unique and i don't
get it but you know because there are 21
year olds that are trying to kill him on
every play when one's coming
one's coming this week and chase young
too exactly that
somebody that chase young as for for the
washington football team already says he
wants him and it's funny
aryan said you know that you know
obviously they're going to have their
hands full with chase young but this may
be one of those situations that be
careful what you wish for
is what aryan said this week
hey see but the thing is you'll never
hear tom talk like that
right right you know right he'll just
take that in
and he'll read that oh going up okay
i am so looking forward to that i guess
if dorian dorian gray didn't have a
dg-12 system you know what i mean like
there wasn't some sort of
there wasn't some sort of dietary plan
or or life plan
that clearly brady is following to the
team here and there's discipline and
then there's you know i won't eat
a tomato because it's too inflammatory
and
you know listen uh you gotta you gotta
hand it to the guy the guy is the most
focused individual
i mean he's really incredible it's kind
of
amazing to watch and i just want to see
how this plays out i mean there's
certain teams that
clearly are the teams to beat and we've
really struggled against the saints and
they look
really good um as to
the chiefs you know no doubt about the
packers too the green bay packers have
looked
tremendous absolutely and and rogers is
uh looking all world again he's really
back in form so
i mean you know there's there's some
teams to beat out there
uh but you know with every week that
tv 12 survives
he the threat mounts especially with
some of the elements that he's brought
in
to you know i mean the fact that
gronkowski is there
and has been slowly getting back into
form himself
you know and others uh i'm man
this is shaping up to be exciting hey
look but michael look at you
not many five seeds demand
a national spotlight at night on a
playoff weekend i mean there's a
specific reason why the bucks
are the first night game of the weekend
the whole
country is going to be interested in
exactly what you're saying about
just how long can brady keep it going
snap to snap quarter to quarter year to
year my god
it is one of the most fascinating sports
stories of our generation
and i don't think i'm overstating it i i
really you know
and i can't wait to to watch all that no
again no that's uh
michael chiklis here on the rich eyes
let's talk about coyote i i
wasn't just saying that because you were
on hold i mean the commercials for this
show
uh are intriguing to say the least and
it looks like you're you've got a a heck
of a program on your hands
so i'll give you this [ __ ] you're
welcome i'm proud of this one i i really
am
you know i'm as proud of this as
anything i've ever worked on in my life
and for a number of different reasons um
authenticity being
number one you know my my dear old
friend
michelle mclaren who i've known for
well i don't know uh close to 30 years
like 27 years now
we met in vancouver when i was shooting
kamish
um and we've we you know she and my wife
have been
dear friends we celebrate a birthday
together and
with all these years that we've
celebrated our birthdays
together we've always said we want to
work together and for the audience
michelle mclaren
is one of the best directors in this
industry she
is known for directing more episodes
than being an executive producer on
breaking bad
as well as game of thrones and uh
you know so many other seminal
uh television series over the last two
three decades you know she's
incredibly talented um and it's just a
brilliant thoughtful
uh filmmaker and visualist and we've
always wanted to work together never had
the opportunity
and two and a half years ago she calls
me out of nowhere and she says chicky i
have it i found it
this is what we're going to do together
we had dinner together she pitched
coyote to me
and we went into development of the
script ended up getting the great uh
david graziano on board as our
showrunner and he's just been an
incredible thoughtful
collaborator and writer and it was very
important to the three of us to go down
and shoot this in mexico
and really you know because in the same
way that
that the shield demanded that we shoot
it in
los angeles because los angeles was
another
character in the play we needed to shoot
this
in in baja california and you know that
i mean
it's just one of those those rare
opportunities where
you're you're surrounded by incredible
talented people who are like-minded
and we wanted to do something um
that was of the ilk of a breaking bad or
or it's the shield where you know where
we take
a hot button political topic
and reduce it to the human element and
we don't
get political with it we just tell human
stories
representing multiple points of view and
all of its
sort of ambiguity and
uh you know and hope that the audience
will
go for the ride be really entertained
and make up their own mind about what
they think about all of this
and that's what i feel like we've done
the only problem was
we were in we were in the middle of
shooting seven of ten
and we were waylaid by a little
something called
covet 19. so well you know we only got
to
finish six episodes so this is an
abridged
season but we're very hopeful that we'll
get to go and do more because
there's so much more to say and do
um but what we have is six really
incredible
compelling hours of television and it
really just sets the pick for the rest
of it
so um you know what what i love also is
that
you know we live in a time where our all
the nuance
has been stripped from our political
discourse
you are either for something or you're
against it
you know there's no gray area and i
think that
film and television and art in general
are the places
the opportunities that we have to go
into all the nooks and crannies of any
given topic
so that we can speak openly and honestly
about any
uh of these topics and have you know
really
come through it as as a as a country
together
as opposed to just being torn apart and
and that kind of discourse is absolutely
necessary and what i i'm proud to be
affiliated with people who are
so thoughtful about these things and so
inclusive
and we i really feel like we're on to
something here and i just
i can't wait for you guys to see it i
don't know not to take myself so
seriously it's not bad it's just
it's just nice to be on something that
you really feel passionately you know
you wake up five minutes before your
alarm clock goes off you know what i'm
saying
no doubt and clearly we could just see
hear your passion in your voice michael
chiklis talking about again coyote
uh on cbs all access all six episodes
that were shot before the pandemic
shutdown production can be available to
be
streamed and binge watched uh starting
this thursday
i'll support anything that you uh
consider important i love when you come
on this show
um and you of course and and and and i i
say that even though you
took the platform to remind me that my
favorite team's dynasty has been over
for ten years and i appreciate all that
and today i'm right there with you man
you know that was a commiseration
no i
my hackles may be up with the whole
boston new york thing um
and so if if i'm feeling heckled
if you you know if if it was intended as
a commiseration i say i appreciate it
and if not
if not i'll say i'm glad that you're
back here in los angeles so you got a
front row seat to see mookie betts win
uh championships for the los angeles
dodgers so
there's that
[Music]
look uh i appreciate the time michael
best your family but
tb tb12 is good everybody's good the
your pug is fine
it's good he's good man he's got fat
unlike the
[Laughter]
there's no there's no tv 12 pug system
there's no pug tv 12 system for the puck
no no he doesn't care about playability
here
he's very inflamed
by the way a pug concerned about
pliability
might be more unique than the actual
tb12 i'll be uh i'll be very honest with
you
thanks for the call michael congrats on
coyote in advance let's chat soon
cheers right back everybody's michael
chiklis at michael chiklis on both
twitter and instagram